okay so hello welcome to this conference
and this talk thanks for coming out just
a brief introduction this is kind of
about me and three senses or less and
it's the only joke in this talk so I'm
glad somebody enjoyed it so I'm a data
scientist in Philadelphia I work for a
company called cadent we place bids on
ad space and for cable TV so that's one
of the main things that we do and the
data science team there most of our work
is around the bidding process so a
couple disclaimers about this talk is
it's mostly going to be useful for new
or newer data scientists but hopefully
there's takeaways for everybody and I'm
gonna apply things and some of the
guidelines examples that give aren't
like they're meant to be illustrative
and not comprehensive and I'm kind of
going for breath and not depth so if you
have more in-depth questions you know
ask after the talk or come find me
during the conference it'd be great to
talk about it I'm going to go fast and
sometimes things that seem obvious need
to be said out loud I've you know as
I've learned from experience so I
realized afterwards when I was looking
at some of these slides if it's like man
that's kind of obvious but it does need
to be said so getting right into it the
goal of this talk is just to discuss
guidelines and practices for robust
model evaluation especially model
evaluation in industry as opposed to
evaluating models and setting like a
goal where you're trying to reach the
top of the leaderboard like that's good
or like you know evaluating a model or
an algorithm so you can publish it
that's good too we need those things but
this is more like inside of industry how
can you deploy with confidence because
you've evaluated your model well another
actually I'll say another side goal
would be to to just talk about this more
I think this is a topic that could be
covered a little bit better you know
within this community it's kind of the
thing that you can really only get by
talking to other people who are doing it
which is why conferences like this are
great so again if anybody has any
feedback I'd love to hear it after this
talk I think it's a good conversation to
have so the outline is we're just going
to briefly talk about the motivation for
why we would want to talk about this and
then we'll kind of talk about evaluation
throughout three segments of sort of
like product lifecycle or like data
science project life cycle which I'm
just gonna label before development
during development and then deployment
and beyond so the motivation is all
models are wrong if you think about it
nearly every way that we formulate sort
of the underlying ideas behind our
models we're admitting that the models
are wrong so we're minimizing a loss
function which is like choosing the
least wrong model we call our models an
estimate right we have like maximum
likelihood estimations as a wife finding
model parameters we incorporate an error
term excuse me directly into like the
definition of our estimates we talk
about probability distribution over the
model parameters the things that we use
to make a prediction so fundamentally
we're always sort of like you know
subconsciously at least admitting that
our models are wrong but it's not just
the theory that tells us that this is
what we do every day right and who's fit
a model and then check this error on the
data set and saw something like this
this is you know this is it this is a
wrong model but this is what happens on
this is like one of our worst days right
on a better day it looks like this it's
still wrong but it looks better but the
key is this might be something that we
could actually use which brings us to
the well-known quote that all models are
wrong but some are useful and that's
kind of the key to this talk right as we
know that our models are wrong but we
can tolerate a little bit of error in in
production right we can tolerate a
little bit of error in practice but
being able to discern you know how much
is too much that's that's the key and
because we're at PI data I'll call this
the Zen of model evaluation and I'll
just break it into like four points all
models are wrong some are useful others
are not and usefulness counts and so we
want to be able to distinguish between
the some that are useful the others that
are not and usefulness the application
that's what really matters we don't
really care about like what means
squared error is or categorical cross
entropy if you know
it doesn't add value to a product so in
health care you know getting this wrong
you know could be measured like with
lives or in advertising space I work in
its measured in dollars we need to get
it right so you know kind of getting
right into it now before development
this phase is like highly context
specific but it's essential for the rest
of the project if you don't start
thinking about evaluation how you're
going to evaluate your model you know
during training and in production before
you start developing it's it's probably
too late the rest of the project kind of
you know hinges on getting this right
and these are some of the obvious things
that might need to be set out loud some
of the hazards of getting this wrong is
your model doesn't actually solve the
problem you're interested in or it only
indirectly solves it you give the user
something that's kind of awkward and
then they don't end up using it it's not
exactly giving them the answer that they
wanted it or you know you can't actually
evaluate the model and production which
leads to like reduced confidence in the
model again you know if users aren't
using it it's not useful right so and if
people don't have confidence in the
model what why would they use it you
know so being able to you know sort of
have a roadmap and keep this thing in
mind from the very beginning is
important because you want to be able to
prove that the model is helpful so that
the users can benefit from it or you hit
like a point of diminishing returns I
think we could probably all raise our
hands and say yeah I spend a lot of time
at least once in my life like constantly
tweaking these hyper parameters of a
model and at the end of the day it
really didn't make a difference if you
kind of have some basic goals in mind it
can you know keep you from doing that
and like you know future iterations
could also be impaired if you don't get
this right and you know we'll talk about
that a little bit later so again this is
like highly context specific so some
guidelines for this is just some things
to think about in the before development
phase
so think about framing the problem I
think I've realized that
I've been doing this for about four
years and I think I've realized that one
of the biggest value ads you can bring
as a data scientist to a company is to
help people who aren't data scientists
frame the problems in a way that are
suitable for machine learning like you
know the things we do are somewhat
unfamiliar to engineers and you know
product people and things like that and
that's great we all specialize in our
own things so working together and
helping to frame the problem in a way
that you know we can build a robust
model and actually evaluate it some some
questions that you should be able to
give clear answers to how are we going
to evaluate this model Howlett success
be measured you should be able to give
an answer such as I'm going to improve
some business objective by you know some
measurable quantity and that could be
you know several different things again
is this more appropriate framed us a
classification or regression problem
seems obvious but it's a you know comes
from experience that you really need to
think that through choose your metrics
and KPIs carefully some guidelines for
that would be try to choose metrics that
convert easily into business value or
business terminology so for example you
know mean absolute percent error is nice
it converts nicely into business terms
you can say yeah our predicted bid
prices are within five percent of the
winning bid price and you know that's
easy to disseminate that information
among other teams so when possible try
and do that and comparability choose
metrics that can be compared across time
across data sets across iterations you
want to not all metrics can do that and
so you want to make sure that what
you're looking at is really comparing
apples to apples if you're going to roll
out a new version of your model you want
to make sure that the criteria it's
being evaluated on makes sense compared
to the previous iteration so think about
deployment and future iterations before
you start development I worked with
somebody who once said nothing is more
permanent than temporary
and I think that's a great quote so
prepare for deployment and future
iterations so for example if you want to
roll out your model the next iteration
using like a/b testing or something like
that think about what sort of
infrastructure requirements that has
what sort of requirements is that going
to impose on your actual API you'll
probably need to be like if you're
exposing your model behind the REST API
for example you'll probably need to be
passing back model ID or something like
that so you can track the performance
from one one version of the model verse
another
and think about the feedback loop this
is essential right I've worked on many
many projects in different industries
where this is not as straightforward as
you would like to think that it is it's
not always easy to tie the outcome to
the model predictions for a variety of
reasons and there's a lot of subtleties
here but a couple of examples are like
ad recommendations a user can't click on
an ad that they weren't shown so your
model might predict across the bunch of
ads but if they're only showing one they
can only click one you know if you don't
think about this carefully you may never
be able to evaluate how you know maybe
your second best predictions are doing
in production or another example suppose
you work for a hospital and you have a
model that's predicting if somebody's
likely going to be readmitted to the
hospital in the next 60 days and the
hospital goes and takes that prediction
and people who are classified as yes
they will be back within the next 60
days the hospital tries to do an
intervention you know some sort of
measure to keep them from coming back so
there in fact there you know the use
case of the model is essentially trying
to change the predicted label right so
now you might end up asking yourself and
you look at the results is the model
that bad or that good right so you may
have a lot of predictions and these
people never came back but maybe it was
that good you identified the people that
were going to come back and the
intervention prevented them from doing
so right so again these are things to
think about in the end the end process
so this brings us to during development
this is probably the most generalizable
phase and I think it's a good
opportunity like amongst the team to
adopt and standardize
best practices I think I said in the
abstract of this talk they've like these
things are better thought of as like a
playbook than a rule book but sometimes
it is good to have sort of like a
foundation of principles so there's a
couple other data scientists from cadent
here
with me and this is one of the things
that we've tried to do is you know
within reason to find some best
practices for how well valuate models so
the first thing is test your assumptions
write garbage in garbage out we all know
that this is probably the thing that I
like and least inclined to do I want to
get it data set and fit it right away
but this is super important you know if
there's an issue with your data there's
going to be an issue with your model
check the distributions of your data
check the features the ranges the
distributions etc against what you know
other subject matter matter experts you
know within you you know your business
your industry or company are saying
about the data if there's disparities
between what you found and what people
are saying you should find be able to
account for that maybe there's an issue
with your ETL or you need to revisit
like the data understanding the business
understanding but again this is one of
those things that in terms of workflow
implement it early to keep you from
wasting lots of cycles trying to get a
model to fit the data that's not you
know that has some sort of fundamental
issue so just for example recently I was
working on a project and I came across
something like this where it was like a
binary classification project so I
basically plotted the distribution
separated by you know the label 0 and
the label 1 of a certain feature and
this feature I thought would be very
useful for actually predicting the
outcome so I expected something like
this I expected the distributions of
this feature to be very different
depending on what class it belonged to
but in reality it was something like
this they were nearly identical which
explains why you know I had trouble
fitting the model so this is something
good to implement early you know again
test your assumptions what I learned
from this was ok I didn't quite
understand the date of the way that I
thought I did I need to go
and you know pull it again differently
another thing that I think is very
useful is to establish a baseline so I
would say like a good baseline is easy
to implement easy to understand and it's
simple but it's not a straw man right so
this should be when I think of a
baseline it's like something that if you
had to you could probably deploy within
a sprint and you would be confident that
it's working correctly and this is just
you know your base performance if any
more complicated model can't you know
beat your baseline then maybe you need
to go back and revisit the data
understanding revisit the business
understanding or or you know maybe you
just don't have the the resources you
need to be able to solve the problem at
that time where you need to frame the
problem differently so some examples a
simple heuristic so a concrete example
of this is I used to work in healthcare
and one of the models that we were
interested in there was if somebody had
this disease last year will he have it
this year and so you know a heuristic
for that is there's lots of diseases and
conditions that we know are chronic so
we could say well if this person had
this condition last year this chronic
condition we assume they have it this
year you know it's kind of on the
borderline of that like simple but kind
of a straw man because you know it's not
going to work for all the conditions but
it still kind of gets you in the
ballpark of what you should expect a
model to be able to be another example
is we predict ratings at Caden and so
one of the things is like that's just a
simple heuristic to form a baseline is
you know well let's just assume that
like the ratings on cable aren't really
changing much week over week so let's
use last week's we rating and use that
as our prediction and be honest it's a
it's a pretty good baseline to use
because they actually don't change much
week over week there's things like
seasonality where that that approach
will break down but again it gives you a
ballpark of where you want to be
an interpretable model is another great
example so you know something like a
linear model logistic regression linear
regression something like a tree based
model where you could inspect the
features again just to give you an idea
that you're on the right track so
another example I won't really go into
the details of this project but I worked
on a project and one feature kept
shooting up to the top and I couldn't
explain why it was unexpected and then
you know come to find out that that
feature was actually leaking information
about the target fail variable
information that we wouldn't have at
runtime so you know would have caused an
issue if it was something that we
deployed the production and was
something we were able to catch early so
that's sort of another side benefit you
can get from using an interpretable
model another good example is like in
the keynote right we saw just recently
you know the speaker took like these
deep learning models and compared it
against something like XG boost where
most of us are probably familiar with
you know gradient boosted trees and that
sort of thing and again it's a good
baseline to say you know there's a lot
of like costs they're deploying some of
these deep learning models well it
should definitely be able to do better
than something that's a little bit
simpler if it's going to be worth the
cost of putting into production and it
was so that's good it's you know
reaffirming that yes this deep learning
model is really worth the effort if you
have an existing model or methodology
some sort of business logic or heuristic
that's already in production obviously
this is your baseline and if you have an
acceptance criteria like this model if
the precision is less than 80 percent or
whatever it may be it's not going to be
useful you know that's like your
baseline and then of course you just
choose like whichever one might be the
best out of all these or but whichever
one you want to work with again it's
like a playbook not a not a rule book
here so another topic that's useful to
think about in terms of model evaluation
is cross validation which is usually
when we see it it's introduced as like
k-fold cross-validation we all kind of
know how that works right
like partition your data into say ten
ten sets ten partitions and trained on
nine tests on wall and trainer now in
testicle in one and that's good
one thing though that we found useful at
Kayden is the a form of cross-validation
that sort of replicates the deployment
pattern a little more closely and this
is something that looks a little bit
more like back testing if you've seen
that if you know you've worked in
finance or you know looked at like
trading algorithms that sort of thing
basically what they'll do there is you
know they'll go back and simulate how
would my model have done in the market
you know if I deployed it six months ago
and so we often do a similar thing here
where you know to keep it really simple
let's say our deployment pattern is
we're going to train on one month
predict on the next month then train on
that month predict on the next so your
cross-validation could be like train on
January predict on February train on
February predict on March you know it's
pretty easy to implement it avoids
leakage from future examples right into
your cross-validation the models only
ever to see what only ever able to see
what happened in the past during train
time which is good and it's more like
what's going to happen in reality when
you start training this model for
production another useful example is
sometimes it's worth training on a
cleaner data set so you know if you have
a data set that you know may be a little
bit noisy or something like that you
have an algorithm that say you're a
little bit unfamiliar with this is where
I found this to be useful you sort of
want to separate that noise in the data
set from the error that you see at train
time so to give a concrete example again
I mentioned we predicted ratings right
which could be formulated in terms of
like time series and deep learnings all
the rage right now right so you know the
idea I had as well maybe we could use
like an LSD N or a convolutional neural
network or something like that right to
solve this problem it seems like
something that we could try
and so our team walked into this one of
the things I looked into in the
beginning was well I didn't do this in
the beginning I wish I did so what I did
was we're really interested in
predicting some sort of rating that only
makes sense inside of our own internal
Cayden you know business structure which
is a little bit noisy but we have access
to national ratings which is much
cleaner and the two data sets that are
very analogous to one another a lot of
the same features are shared between the
two data sets so you know I could try
those approaches using CNN or an LST or
something like that on the national data
set something that I know is a little
bit cleaner that I know if I'm seeing
all sorts of weird errors it's probably
I've implemented the model wrong or I
need more regularization or something
like that and it's not just yeah this
data is noisy I didn't pull it correctly
I missed something or you know so yeah
that's it on that now we hit deployment
and beyond and again this is what really
matters right we really care about
performance in production and this is
there's a lot of things to say about
this phase but I guess I'll kind of talk
about just two things in this talk is
one you really want to ensure that your
model is useful and that it stays useful
and you want to be able to iterate with
confidence and so of course once you
deploy a model it's a production you
know you're tying the predictions to the
outcomes and you're gonna do some
evaluations but there are things and
that's like a no-brainer and we're
probably all doing that it's a good
first step
here's some other things that I think
are useful in addition to that so one is
a be testing I'm not really going to go
into a whole lot of details on a/b
testing I assume oops most people here
are used to it or familiar with the idea
but I this is a great pattern so why
would you want to do a/b testing so
let's assume this plot is like the
models error over time in production and
this red line represents a new release
right so it kind of looks like the
models error has dropped since the new
release
but has it really like we're data
scientists right don't we want to give
like a more like scientific answer as to
just saying like yeah we looked at the
plot it dropped because who knows like
maybe it's going to rise up again in the
future
you don't know so a/b testing is like a
great mechanism where you can deploy
iteratively you know send 5% of your
traffic to the new model 95% of traffic
to the existing model and start doing
comparisons and eventually just ramp up
the traffic that you're sending to the
new model as you gain confidence in it
you know while you're performing these
hypothesis tests until eventually the
new iteration is handling all of the
traffic and one other thing that I think
is the last thing I'm going to mention
is monitoring which you know could cover
a wide range of things but some of the
things that I think you would really
want to think about monitoring it's like
monitoring the the input data looking
for things like covariant shift and
stuff like that where the distribution
of the data at runtime is different from
the distribution of the data at train
time and you know that obviously is like
a topic all in itself two useful
guidelines that came from a paper on
tensorflow extended which is sort of
like you know put out by the tensorflow
developers it's sort of like production
pipeline kind of infrastructure thing
for tensorflow models as they said you
know keep it simple and keep it
actionable and I think this is useful
right so in an example they give is like
if you're monitoring for deviations in
runtime data from train time data you
know favor looking at ranges over
something like coal back Leibler
divergence right like if you look at you
know if you get a report and says the KL
divergence is greater than this or
exceeded some threshold like how it's
hard to understand that and it's also
hard to understand what the action you
should take us but if you get an alert
that says for this numeric feature we
saw values that are
you know five times greater than the
largest value we saw during training
that's a little bit more actionable
that's something that you can look into
a little bit more often you can monitor
how many times those things happen or
look you know if you're receiving input
from categorical variables and you're
seeing new values that you never saw
before there may be legitimate reasons
for that perhaps you have new vendors
new products whatever but maybe it's an
indication that you need to retrain the
model so that it can sync with the data
that it's currently seeing at run time
and another good thing too that I think
as a guideline to try and reimplemented
each X that you looked at during
development during this phase so I
actually had a slide on sanity checks
and I removed it but I would just say
sign each X I think we were all doing
them already
during training is you know we're
looking at future importances and/or
coefficients of the models things like
that making sure they make sense we're
looking at the ranges that of like say
we're doing regression we're looking at
the ranges of what the models predicting
making sure that we're not predicting
things that are you know way large
bigger than what we would really expect
to see and those sanity checks could be
reintroduced sort of in the post
deployment phase where you could monitor
for those things as well so if you've
already integrated them into your
workflow during training they're great
things to carry over here maybe you can
hand them off to QA or something like
that and those are things they can check
for and so that's it right now
so in conclusion hopefully there are
some takeaways one of the things that I
appreciate about these conferences is I
think you know there's a lot of
opportunity to learn from other people
who are doing this and so hopefully
you've learned something and I would
love for you to share your suggestions
this is definitely an area that I could
grow in I think the team I work with we
can all grow in I think this industry
can grow in so you know afterwards I'd
love to hear what sort of practices you
guys have in development
and lastly there's a link here in the
slides which I think the conference will
link to the conference will link to the
slides and slides link to a blog post
where I took basically the contents of
this talk and I put it into a post and
it's on my blog and there's a little bit
more information there so if you want
more that's where it is and I guess now
we can open up for questions
[Applause]